the nominees for Best Original Song are
you don't know if you're gonna win
you can ask faith to pray who believed
you know put it all out there have
confidence you know - your name is
called John Stephens and Lonnie Lynn for
glory
I felt really moved because they called
the names we were born with which is
Loni Lynne and John Stevens so to hear
our names and you know my father he had
just passed and my name is his name so
it's kind of like I felt a lot of homage
and what was going on Oprah was there to
give me a little like hand clapping I
didn't know that she was giving it to me
and I missed it I mean I went to David O
yellow first because I thought Oprah was
doing that to John so just I always want
to make it clear that I wouldn't went to
Oprah but I didn't want to play myself
and I actually felt like I ended up
playing Oprah but I didn't mean to my
mother had come in town with all of like
my next-door neighbors and friends and
family I felt like a joy that I was
doing it not only for me but it felt
like it was for like a whole community
for including my family the hip-hop
community the people that were you know
there's going through the struggles this
bridge was once a landmark of a divided
nation but now was the symbol for change
I try to do my best to just feel like I
was present but you know you get an
excitement that you can't explain to
people it was like a feeling of probably
one of the greatest joys I ever had in
my life
[Applause]